[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Tonight inshallah we want to speak
about an issue that we need to be honest
with ourselves. elves about
if we hope to correct this part of
ourselves.
This is the point that we have reached
in our reflection
on surah mur.
We've reached the verses of surah althur
that deal with a man that was incredibly
influential in his time. And not only
that, but he was trusted and well
respected.
Alwel
Mural
Wal's father.
This was a household of great honor, was
a household of incredible generosity.
And these are not just stories that we
learn about.
These are things that help us to
understand the Quran
and in turn help us to administer the
medicine of the Quran on ourselves and
on our hearts.
The Quran is a medicine
but you have to let it in in order for
it to take effect and you have to take
it properly in the proper dosage. You
have to take the right parts of it at
the right time in order for it to have
the desired effect.
The issue that we want to speak about
this evening
is regarding how many of us
think
for ourselves truly
and how many of us
merely
hold the opinions of others.
Now this doesn't mean that we don't
trust our scholars. This doesn't mean
that we don't trust our prophets. This
doesn't mean that we don't trust each
other. That's not the point here. The
point is how many of us
with regards and respect to the things
that we are able to think about for
ourselves and reach a conclusion.
So for instance, a complex issue in
a complex issue in
these are things that you need tools in
order to be able to deal with them.
It's not that everybody can just jump in
and give their own opinion. A person who
is not a person of knowledge does not
have an opinion.
An opinion is earned. It's something
that you learn and you earn the
responsibility of holding an opinion
with regards to Islam.
That's a different topic. We're not
speaking about that. You trust the
scholar. You trust the companions,
the
the imams of Islam. You trust them
because you do not possess the tools and
resources that they had knowledgewise in
order to come to a conclusion. But how
about the things that you can come to a
conclusion on?
Those are things you are responsible for
thinking for yourself,
not just to jump on the
bandwagon. If many of us were to really
really be honest with ourselves, with
ourselves, and really reflect,
reflect on the things that make you
angry, the things that make you happy,
the things that you take as un
undeniable
truths about the world around us,
opinions on people, opinions on
countries, opinions on races.
Where have we gotten the majority of
those opinions? Most of us to fancy
and think that, oh, these are these are
opinions I've come to on my own.
But is it really is it really an opinion
that you've come to on your own? A
conclusion that you've arrived at after
thinking and weighing things on your
own? This is a question we have to ask
ourselves because we have been trained
in this time
in this super break neck speed
information coming at you left and
right. Lies being told and gushed into
your mind at every turn.
In this time and in this place,
whether we to admit it or not,
there are very good aspects to this
country. maybe aspects that we don't
even have in our own Muslim countries.
Fantastic.
However, with regards to propaganda
and with regards to
leading the charge
in changing the fra of humanity and
evil, this is the belly of the beast.
Right here we are in the nest where
Shaitan came and laid his eggs and they
have hatched.
That's where we live right now. To play
games with words and chew water and act
that's not the case is only going
to weaken our position more.
This is where all new ideas,
androgyny, homosexuality, zena,
ultra consumerism,
lies, propaganda, things that would make
Hitler and Stalin proud. They come from
right here. We've mastered that in this
country. And I say that as an as an
American. I was born here.
Now,
if we understand the situation that
we're in, the question is the opinions
you hold. Whose opinions are they? And
what does this have to do with?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us about
a man named Mu
wasn't just some guy. I want you to
imagine yourself having grown up in
Mecca.
These were your heroes. Abu Jahel, he
was not called Abu Jah. He was called
Abu Hakim,
the man of extreme
justice and fairness.
Abu Sufyan Sakbar
Abu Leah who was referred to as Abu
Leah a reference to burning embers
because of how he had the redness in his
cheeks. So he's referred to as Abu Lahab
because he was so wealthy and he was
such of such nobility and royalty in
Mecca that he didn't have to walk in the
sun ever. The sun never had to touch his
skin.
And so that's why red and white was
considered a sign of nobility during
those times. They don't get a tan. They
don't walk out in the sun. That's for
the peasants.
He was called Abuahab because of that.
These are your heroes growing up.
Whenever there's a war, a battle,
whenever there's an issue, these are the
men that you go to. You grew up with
your father going to sitting in these
gatherings and seeing these menf
Abuahab Abu Jah.
You you grew up seeing them sitting on
the thrones of the Arabs or as close to
a throne as as they had. These were the
men that you looked up to. These were
the men that you hoped would be at your
wedding. These are the men that you
hoped would name your children for you.
This is the kind of environment these
men were in.
And so you've grown up and you've spent
so much of your life looking up to these
men and fighting for them. In certain
cases, if you were 15 or above, you were
going to war for these men. you would
protect them and their honor with your
dying breath and that was considered
your duty.
So the question is
if you grew up in this environment
and a man came and said he was a prophet
and these men said he is a liar, he is a
magician, he is a madman, he is a poet,
cut him off, berate him, belittle him,
humiliate him, laugh at him. only
followers this man who claims to be a
prophet, the only followers he has are a
handful of slaves and women.
Which side would you be on?
That's a question you have to ask
yourself. How strong is propaganda and
how susceptible are you to it?
It's not hard to find the answer to that
question. Just look at the opinions you
hold today. Where did they come from?
Who told you that? Why do you get upset
when Twitter tells you to get upset? And
why aren't you upset when Twitter
doesn't tell you to be upset?
What are the things that anger us? What
are the nononsense not open to debate
issues?
If I were to ask you right now, who is
the greatest villain in modern history?
Who popped into your mind right now? And
who told you that?
It's okay. This is not a an attack. This
is a diagnosis. We're trying to diagnose
ourselves.
It's very easy for us as Muslims to say,
"Oh yeah, of course I would have been on
the right side. Of course, I would have
been with the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. If I was with him, I would
have and I would have and I would have."
Everybody says that in their mind.
But look at yourself today. Whose side
are you on?
Who do you stand for?
How many of the prophet's heirs today?
I'm not speaking about those who claim
to be from his, you know, lineage.
That's not what I'm talking about. His
heirs, his those who inherit from him.
His heirs are the scholars of Islam. And
not just any scholars but those who
upholdahill
to its fullest extent.
They reject and refuse any type of shik.
They reject and refuse any type of
innovation. Those are the people of
knowledge. Those who have a lineage of
knowledge that goes back to the prophet
Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam. If I were
to ask, if we were to ask ourselves, how
many of those heirs could you name right
now?
Do you know who they are? Are you on
their side? Because from the moment that
Allah sent to the prophet Muhammad
Sallallam,
the people were divided at that moment.
those who believed and those who
disbelieved. And that division will
continue until the day of judgment, the
day of resurrection. It never ended. It
did not end. It's going on right now
still.
So the question is when we look at these
verses here, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us about
wasn't just a nice guy or nobility
made most of the swords that you're
carrying because he was a well-known
blacksmith, very very skilled at that.
He had so much wealth that he had to use
all of the gates of Mecca at the same
time to be able to get his caravan into
the city.
That is how much wealth he had. They
couldn't all come in through one door.
It would take him days to get through
that door.
slaughtered 10 camels every single day
throughout the entire Hajj season for
anyone who has come to Hajj for the
pilgrims.
Ali
would make the cloak of the Kaa every
other year himself on his own with his
own wealth. And every other year all of
the rest of the tribes of Quraysh would
get together to to cloak it every year.
So he was referred to as
he is equal. He is one who is equal to
all of in his generosity.
If you or I lived in Mecca before the
prophet sallall.aii Wasam,
there's not a household who wasn't
affected by's
generosity.
You or I could have very easily gotten
married with wealth that he gave us or
in a lima that he threw for us or from a
daughter that he went to ask for her
hand for us or because of blood money
that he paid on your behalf. He had a
min on everyone in Mecca. This is what
we're talking about, right? And now the
prophet Muhammad sallallah.aii wasallam,
he's known for his honesty. He's known
for his great character, but he wasn't
involved this.
And so now he comes and says
and he recites the Quran
and
those with him all start to go against
him and tell the youth and tell everyone
and hold meetings. Don't listen to him.
He is lying. He just wants to do this.
This is the reason he's saying this and
that's the reason he's saying this and
bring up all kinds of rumors. He's
crazy.
He has gins attack him. He's been
learning from the people of the book and
claiming that it's him. He's got a devil
that comes and whispers to him the
Quran. It's not from him. It's not from
Gibl or Allah. Propaganda. I saw him do
this. Look who became Muslim. That guy.
And that guy is a known scumbag. Right?
This is how propaganda works.
Are you strong enough
to reject that?
Which side would you have been on?
Which side would you have been on? And
so we now sit back 1500 years later and
we look back and say, how could these
people dare to unshath their swords on
the prophet of Allah?
However, that's because we are very
we are very u we are very distant
from the situation. We aren't involved
in a very delicate way.
There's a narration and we will end with
this for today
in Muslim during the battle of
during the battle of Aland the battle of
the trench or the confederates
it was so cold and the companions were
so scared.
It was so cold that night that they were
taking all the clothes. Each one of them
had to take every piece of clothing from
the house, even their wives clothing to
put on themselves because it was so
bitter cold.
And they were so frightened because the
only thing it seemed to be hanging by a
thread
of these thousands of men spilling
into Medina and having their way with
it. And so it was dark, it was cold, it
was night, and it was uncertain.
And all of the major tribes of the Arab
peninsula
have now gathered around the Medina and
they're just a few meters away from
having their way with Medina. And the
only one that's protecting you from the
back are the people of the book who have
been waiting for this opportunity
to turn against you. So they were very
scared. It was very difficult situation.
And the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam came to the group of companions
dur at that night and it was raining
it was cold. He said who will go and spy
on the
the other army who will go as recon
for reconnaissance go and see where they
are, what they're doing, how many of
them there are and come back to me.
They were already scared inside of
Medina. Now he's asking them to go right
up right up to the tents and look inside
of them.
The companions and this was narrated by
Jabber. They said, "So we all ducked our
heads down."
The companions. Yes. That's how scared
they were. Everyone looked down and
nobody wanted a part of that.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
said
who will go on recon bring us back the
information that we're looking for and
for you I guarantee paradise still none
of them raised their hand
and
mentioned that he started to hunch his
back down and duck down so that he
wouldn't be chosen
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam then chose
the one who was hunched down. He said
you you're going to go
and we'll get to that story inshallah
when we get to and before that the point
is why did jabir tell us this story?
He told us this story because he was
sitting in a gathering with some of the
not companions the next generation after
the prophet had passed away sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and they were having a
conversation about some of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
they were holding this attitude of if I
was there the only thing between me and
being the hero of the Muslims at that
time is is time. If I was there, I would
have done this and done that and I would
have right with regards to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. I would have
protected him and I would have gone to
war and I would have done this and I
would have done that. And so he said to
them, don't say that
we were with him. And then he related
the story of
and the kind of fear that they were
encountering. It's not beneficial to
read these stories they're a fairy
tale or without using your imagination.
You have to go there and be with them in
the circumstances in your mind in order
to truly
draw on and be benefited by the Quran
and the stories of the Quran.
Subhanahu
[Silence]
alhamdulillah.